(light music)
(speaking in foreign language)
- [Narrator] In the center of Havana,
there's a pair of entrepreneurs
who are taking pizza
delivery to new heights.
(speaking in foreign language)
- [Narrator] In 2010,
Marta number one
and her husband were granted
a private business license,
and opened up a pizzeria.
A few months ago, her husband passed away.
Now her best friend is helping
her keep the pizzeria alive.
(speaking in foreign language)
- [Narrator] Since then the pizzeria,
which operates from
Marta number one's roof,
has filled countless stomachs
with their secret recipe.
(speaking in foreign language)
- [Narrator] Ever since Marta number two
joined Marta number one in business,
the two have formed a true partnership.
(speaking in foreign language)
(melancholy music)